est-ce que vous avez lu mon livre vous
savez pourquoi je n'ai pas lu
trop de buzz d'accord
de télé pendant 2 ans c'est pas un drame
RTL oui j'ai essayé de m'en sortir de
cette merde de cette vie oui j'ai
retrouvé mon père mort sur la tombe de
mon frère ma grand-mère au cimetière
j'ai fait une méningite j'en ai chié
toute ma vie j'ai essayé de me sortir de
cette merde j'ai même envoyé ma
candidature à Monsieur Hanouna pour
devenir rubriqueur peut-être vous l'avez
jamais vu j'ai tout fait j'ai tout fait
mais par contre par contre j'étais
bouché enfin je gagne ma vie et j'ai
toujours caché mon métier je l'ai caché
mon métier parce que je voulais me
sortir de cette merde je suis végétarien
je mange pas d'animaux j'allais j'allais
non mais ouais et je vous dirai ce qui
se passe aussi dans les abattoirs mais
attendez vous êtes en train de
décrépiller
pourquoi vous avez caché votre métier
c'est d'être bouché une honte que vous
venez de faire devant tous les Français
pourquoi parce que je suis pas un
menteur parce que
en moyenne surface qui sont jetés à la
poubelle tant d'animaux tués pour rien
et vous me dites vous me reprochez rien
du tout excusez-moi parcours personnel
oui je suis un parcours personnel et je
le revendique voilà
[Applaudissements]
sur la
moi depuis que je suis votre émission je
vais être d'accord avec Gilles
je me sens pas bien
incroyable c'est la coupe de cheveux ça
et je vais encore répondre une chose à
ce monsieur il y a dans on est pas
nombreux emboucherie on cherche
énormément de boucher parce qu'il en
manque là-dessus maman beaucoup de
boucher il y a une chose qui s'appelle
le droit de retrait le droit de retrait
moi personnellement on me force à rien
si je estime que ce que je fais est mal
je ne le fais pas
vous allez me dire j'ai besoin pour
vivre mais dans le cas là il y a assez
de boucher tout le monde cherche des
bouché ça ça me plaît pas c'est
dégueulasse la farce que vous repassez
là et ainsi de suite c'est dégueulasse
je quitte je pose mon tablier faites
votre misère vous-même j'ai ma
conscience propre du travail pour vous
avez continué vous avez filmé vous avez
écrit un livre si c'est pas pour faire
le bœuf c'est pourquoi en plus vous avez
la RTI personne on n'a jamais entendu
hier on vous a jamais entendu dire ah
là-bas c'est c'est une misère rien pour
moi vous êtes complice et acteur ah
pourtant pourtant le rédacheur en chef
ici j'avais déjà envoyé plein de photos
j'avais déjà envoyé plein de photos
après vous savez vous savez moi je dis
honnêtement et devant toute la France
devant toute la France je dis monsieur
c'est comment
je vous a plu et on peut l'applaudir
tous ensemble parce que continuer à
aller dans les supermarchés continuez à
croire ce monsieur qui est certainement
un bon boucher c'est bien son travail
mais continuer continuer continuer il y
a eu un malheur chez buttoni je peux
vous promettre je vous le promets j'ai
manqué de faire une mourir une personne
à cause de mes chefs parce que non tu
filmes mais parce que mon chef il vient
dans le frigo ils viennent je suis pas
d'accord c'est ouais et un moment
impossible le mec qui met en barquette
le mec qui coupe la viande le mec qui
rentre si c'est vous si vous le
responsable personne ne vous a mis à
côté tu vas vendre le périmé c'est le
supérieur qui est responsable mais
supérieur dans la gestion dans
l'organisation pas dans la magouille
c'est c'est mais là ce que vous dites
c'est c'est on est sur nos dimensions là
vous vous cautionnez vous filmez vous
faites et après vous faites la victime
derrière vous écrivez un lit vous dites
ah ouais la grande surface tous des
tueurs regardez ce que j'ai fait
regardez ce que j'ai fait vous filmez
encore hein et derrière il se passe rien
je suis désolé j'ai pas crédible vous
êtes pas crédible ce que vous reproche
Michael c'est que vous avez travaillé
dans la grande distribution et qu'en
fait
en fait vous êtes
non mais vas-y dis-le
trop longtemps
Cyril mais tout simplement Cyril
pourquoi Cyril pourquoi parce que
j'avais besoin de gagner ma vie un
minimum d'accord parce que les portes se
fermer
il y en a beaucoup c'est très recherché
donc c'est très très recherché c'est
très très
des jeunes qui sont intéressés
et c'est très bien payé enfin c'est très
bien payé